tonight on corridor crew 5 Keanu Reeves
and person a ders and one Keanu Reeves
superfan battle to win America's hearts
in a series of challenges they'll test
their love for Keanu Reeves we have a
matrix single handed cartwheel challenge
we're doing a speed challenge you got to
go fast
while defusing a bomb with the Point
Break test the limits of your adrenaline
with this surfing challenge and finally
a John Luke challenge a duel to the
death where your accuracy and friendship
will be tested
deep within each and every one of us
Keanu Reeves lives tonight you'll figure
out when if he's ready to come out today
I'm representing Keanu Reeves from
cyberpunk 2077 honestly just because I'm
really in for the game neo from the
matrix otherwise known as the one yeah
I'm thinking I'm back I'm John wick I'm
Keano
on a bad day I got blue cheese instead
of cheddar so I'm Keanu Reeves owner of
arch motorcycles and star of all these
movies that people are saying that
they're in a villain head superfan found
his t-shirt got Keanu Reeves on it and
you know it's curious to see what he
goes are up to today all right so for
the first challenge we're doing the
matrix lobby scene we're gonna have to
do a one-handed cartwheel while shooting
an m16 and hitting a live target
zoomy based on accuracy but more
importantly it's gonna be based on if
you can fire that shot off while you're
in midair so since this first round
we're gonna do a double elimination so
the two worst nails are gonna be
eliminated from the competition
because Keon has a charitable person
each one of us gets one second chance to
be used at once during this entire
competition
all right so Jonny silver hands going
first cuz he thinks he's the best Keanu
here oh you think you can do it kind of
like how you could be Tom Cruise in
Jackie Chan honestly dude I had Tom
Cruise I had Jackie Chan I have to win
this if I don't win this I have nothing
like what's the point anymore three two
one
[Music]
Oh
I give you props about thank you wait
from you it means about so next up we
have neo he's gonna give his best
one-handed cartwheel but I mean started
on once before so three two one
neo totally wish the shot by 1d is using
as part of Keanu to get one pair two
ball second chance all right so we got
John wick on deck I have high hopes for
this I'm thinking I'm gonna give this a
shot I'll tell you where I'm at one
chance using my heart of Keanu Allmusic
the same thing John wick should be able
to do this
[Music]
[Applause]
three two one Keanu you have to feel it
three two one Keanu she's alone this is
not surprising this one about as well as
I expected soon we'll see if I still
have what it takes to pass third grade
gym class
Keanu I must sacrifice my heart of kyani
for a second chance
John wick look unfortunately we lost Sam
and we lost rent to fellow Keanu
contenders right now it's myself cliff
Nico and D and we're moving on so in the
movie speed Keanu Reeves was trapped on
a bus with a bomb on it if they dropped
under 50 miles per hour the entire bus
would explode so we're on the stationary
bike today we have to reach 115 rpms on
the highest tension setting you're
presented with an armed bomb you must
defuse the bomb if you drop below 115
rpms you will be alerted with us and
you'll be disqualified so be quick be
smart and hang in there so John wick is
up first we're gonna see if you can keep
the speed up while disarming this bomb
my heart's beating it's gonna be like a
sprint all my hearts are gone this is it
all right it's 115 you know
don't work so hard the t65 tube
I do that in 14 seconds 14 seconds I
gotta go it's gonna come down to like a
milliseconds or it's a giant silver
hands up it's scary not knowing where
your phone is
and you just have to trust it like your
legs are strong
[Music]
maybe about 15 hundredths of a cent
oh my god oh my I remember doing this
back in uh early 90s I didn't have to
use my legs quite as much today we'll
see how this goes
[Music]
I saw 98 on the reader hit the button
I focused on opening the case slowed
down my pedaling I got to use my heart
economy try
No
mio is up okay focus you ready I'm ready
let me go
my legs so tired four of us competed
here two of us blow up the bomb we have
to decide who stays so we all know Keanu
he's a very nice guy he's very humble
he's very giving in turn both of you
guys should have very good hearts speed
compliment round you guys can go back
and forth bouncing off each other and
the first person to hesitate wouldn't
give me a compliment loses you go first
first compliment the you're a great post
for the channel and been a great friend
thanks man
cliff we've worked together for a long
time and I really value that we can
continue to hang out after all these
years it's still be really good friends
didi you're a really good first person
shooter player and a really good gamer
in general Thanks I practice a lot of
you know it honestly you're one of them
you're better shape than most people I
know and it's obviously a it's an
inspiration to see I've been friends
with you for a long time and you've had
many girlfriends and you've been a great
boyfriend to all of them your fashion
sense is really nice it's good to meet
someone else who has very similar style
style as me well I know you you wear
black no no Johnny it's a pleasure I'm
just saying I'd probably win that
endeavour challenge it's real all those
guys are out there saying really nice
things to each other but you know what I
want to say something nice for our
patrons who have gone above and beyond
to support us in the endeavor of making
the videos around here some names come
to mind in particular Jack O'Connell
Bobby Hansel Harris red Zapata Phillip
Oxford L&L Monza
a Canadian spy sneaky snack and Glitch
cube I mean you guys have been
supporting us for so long I can't really
put it into words but just know this
you're my Keanu Reeves if you guys are
interested in supporting these videos
consider going over to
patreon.com/scishow corridor digital
thanks Point Break Keanu Reeves surfer
aficionado falls in love with skydiving
bad boy Patrick Swayze as they rob banks
now this undercover FBI agent must
decide between his heart and his job we
are going to simulate this turmoil I'm
balancing on an Indo board while getting
sprayed with wind and water to represent
the inner turmoil in Johnny Utah's part
the very heart that gave us all a second
chance I saw my heart I'm ready to go
let's do it my legs are really tired so
we'll see if I can last on this I'm
ready
alright so as soon as Clinton has his
balance and the board is off the ground
I'm gonna call start and that's
immediately when the wind's coming in
the waters gonna come in after
you lasted four and a half seconds that
was garbage those trash wait what's
chiana's heart I'm using it I need to
that's the step for technique ping 10-4
here that is absolutely not gonna work
7.7 6 second improvement wait a gun is
so hard to see whoa it's time to be feel
like if not a long time but Clint's
really good on the endo board so to see
him fall that quickly off of it it's a
little concerning
alright Dee's already uses heart so that
means his first try his last try the
stakes are high guys I'm ready it's Tom
alright whenever you're ready I'm ready
I'm ready
yeah it's beginning to believe there is
this book
[Music]
oh man Nico I hope you fall right up but
Wow
if you really like bonus I just focused
dude he was like it's shaping the wind
that was close to losing your I know I
mean I won't be surprised if he lose
it's what you do please stand up for me
[Music]
it's just like Jackie Chan challenger
I'm doing okay there's been out of
commission for a while though I already
thought he's been thinking about coming
back but we'll see yeah all right set
over toys I guess it cuts out again
valiant fight my wrists hurt there was
water in my eyes this hair is hanging
low you know would never do it's making
excuses you know I'm happy I'm happy for
you I'm truly happy it means a lot you
stolen another win from me indeed always
respectable this man cannot win again
you cannot be Tom Cruise and Keanu
Reeves you cannot be tigers and caribou
they're both too cool so it all comes
down to this Keanu Reeves vs. Keanu
Reeves neo vs. John wick it's gonna be a
pistol duel in the hallway the way this
works is we stand back-to-back we're
gonna take a couple steps at which point
the referee will yell roll we roll he's
still up we shoot the cast and we spin
and we shoot at each other that's right
it's a battle to the death whoever it
gets shot lose it whoever survives goes
on to become the office Keanu Reeves
John wick Keanu and neo Keanu we are the
two best with guns so only make sense
that we're the ones that only made it to
this challenge I don't know I feel
pretty confident I roll in two pistols a
lot but I know Nico also does too and he
has dresses John wick so you have that
is going to be a down to the millisecond
fight before you know what we're going
to say go and then it's going to be over
within the seconds Nico I'm sorry but
I'm rooting for D here pretty sure - go
ahead gonna shoot you the same time but
we'll stay yeah all right good luck
thanks man good luck
and well
[Applause]
it's a good tool man holy crap
yeah I got that last hand as a peacock
is spun around to get you but no I did
it it feels great honestly I was honored
to be surrounded by so many good
contenders and competitors you know I
didn't think I was gonna win
now do you gets to wear the sunglasses
and the coat every day now no one can
say it's weird that I wear this outfit
every day as it currently stands
I am the office Tom Cruise D is the
obvious counter e's west of the office
Jackie Chan and Sam is the office
Indiana Jones
we have impersonator Olympics coming up
like the Rock & % a Rolodex Nic Cage
impersonator Lindex mr. breeding
impersonator Olympics I don't know but
if you want us to do one pleasing to
comment below and who you would like us
to do and what some the key challenges
would be who'll be the next champion
well consider subscribing to the channel
to find out